bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une simulation informatique incroyable
qui semble capable de générer des
créature virtuelle à partir de presque
rien elle s'appelle lenia et on peut la
voir comme une sorte d'extension du jeu
de la vie le jeu de la vie vous vous en
souvenez peut-être c'est une simulation
imaginée par John Conway dans les années
1970 et à laquelle j'avais consacré
toute une vidéo et bien l'enia c'est
encore plus fort et encore plus beau que
le jeu de la
vie l'enia tout comme le jeu de la vie
appartient à ce domaine de recherche
qu'on appelle la vie artificielle
l'objectif de cette discipline c'est de
créer des systèmes artificiel dont les
comportements se rapprochent de ceux
qu'on retrouve dans les systèmes vivants
et cela peut se faire de différentes
façons soit en étudiant des réactions
chimiques simples dont les interactions
miment les process essus du vivant soit
en essayant de créer des machines
capables par exemple d'évoluer et de se
reproduire de façon autonome ou bien de
façon plus accessible en créant des
simulations informatiques qui imitent le
vivant mais attention quand je parle
d'une simulation qui imite le vivant je
parle pas d'animer un personnage dans un
jeu vidéo ce qu'on cherche à faire c'est
à créer de l'émergence c'est-à-dire
qu'on veut partir d'un système simple
avec des règles élémentaires mais qui
quand on le simule produisent des
comport macroscopique inattendu c'est
comme ça que fonctionne la vie telle
qu'on la connaît c'est un phénomène
émergent à la base du vivant il y a
simplement si on peut dire un grand
nombre de réactions chimiques mais dont
la combinaison va faire émerger des
processus complexes allant jusqu'à
l'auto-organisation des organismes
vivants aujourd'hui on va donc essayer
d'explorer cette idée d'émergence mais à
partir de règles informatique simple
capable quand on les simule d'engendrer
des comportements complexes et pour ça
revoyons déjà comment fonctionne le jeu
de la vie j'y avais consacré toute une
vidéo que je vous invite à regarder mais
je vais quand même rappeler les bases
tout d'abord le jeu de la vie ça n'est
pas vraiment un jeu puisqu'il n'y a pas
de joueur à proprement parler c'est
juste une simulation qui obéit à ses
propres règles et qu'on peut faire
tourner sur un ordinateur pour ça on
part d'une grille aussi grande qu'on le
souhaite et dont chaque case représente
une sorte de cellule virtuelle qui peut
être soit vivante soit morte
ici je vais représenter les cellules
mortes en noir et les vivantes en jaune
et ensuite on va les faire évoluer au
tour par tour avec deux règles très
simples à chaque tour pour chaque
cellule on regarde ces h voisines et on
compte combien il y en a de vivante la
première règle c'est qu'une cellule
vivante a besoin de deux ou trois
voisines pour se maintenir en vie on
peut dire qu'en dessous de deux elle
meurt d'isolation mais qu'à partir de 4
elle meurt de surpopulation la deuxème
règle c'est que si une case vide est
entourée par exactement trois voisines
vivantes elle devient vivante et voilà
c'est tout à chaque tour pour chaque
cellule on compte les voisines et on
applique ces deux règles pour faire
évoluer la grille pour voir ce que ça
donne on va partir d'une configuration
initiale tirée au hasard par exemple
celle-ci et on va simuler tour après
tour et voici le genre de chose qu'on
obtient au début ça semble assez
aléatoire mais peu à peu on voit des
choses intéressante émerger déjà il y a
des structures isolées qui semblent
stables hein comme celle qu'on voit ici
ou là ensuite il y a des motifs qui
osile entre deux états et puis encore
plus intriguant on a des structures qui
semblent se déplacer en diagonale on les
surnomme des planeurs et ce qui est
absolument fou avec ces planeurs c'est
qu'ils émergent des règles
microscopiques à aucun moment dans le
code on ne dit de prendre telle
structure et de la déplacer sur la
grille il y a aucune notion de
déplacement dans les règles du jeu de la
vie le mouvement apparent des planeurs
émerge des règles d'évolution
microscopiques depuis les années 70 on a
trouvé avec le jeu de la vie toute une
zoologie de motifs localisés de plus en
plus complexe et ayant des propriétés
intéressantes comme le fait d'être
stable d'osciller ou de se déplacer et
même des motifs encore plus riches comme
ces structures capables d'engendrer des
planeurs alors il y a plein d'exemples
très jolis je vais pas tous vous les
montrer je vous invite vraiment à aller
voir la vidéo dédiée si vous av pas déjà
vu car aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut c'est
aller plus loin une chose qu'on peut
déjà se demander c'est est-ce qu'on peut
modifier les règles du jeu de la vie
pour avoir des choses encore plus
intéressantes pourquoi ces deux règles
spécifiquement qu'est-ce qui se passe si
on en essae d'autres la règle usuelle on
la surnomme parfois B3 S23 B3 pour borne
avec trois voisines et S pour survives
avec deux ou trois voisines mais quit
des autres règles possibles par exemple
je sais pas B34 et s125 ça donnerait
quoi et ben ça ne produit rien d'aussi
intéressant il existe en principe deux
puissan 18 règles possibles soit environ
260000 possibilités mais la plupart
conduisent à des situations sans intérêt
comme l'envahissement de la grille par
des cellules vivantes ou au contraire la
destruction totale et très peu de règles
donnent des phénomènes de structure
localisé et rien d'aussi simple et beau
que les règles originelles du jeu de la
vie mais dans ce cas est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas essayer d'aller plus loin
de généraliser les principes du jeu de
la vie et bien c'est ce que fait
l'enia pour comprendre comment on va
construire l'enia il faut réaliser que
le jeu de la vie est ce qu'on appelle
une simulation discrète discrète ici
c'est dans le sens mathématique du terme
ça signifie qu' n'est pas continu et on
va essayer de s'affranchir de ça déjà
dans le jeu de la vie les cellules ont
un état discret elles sont soit vivantes
soit mortees mais pas entre les deux et
bien pour aller plus loin on va
maintenant autoriser n'impor n'importe
quelle valeur entre 0 et 1 ça veut dire
qu'une cellule pourra valoir par exemple
0,67 ou
0,08 si on tire chaque valeur au hasard
pour la situation de départ on aura donc
quelque chose de ce genre ici pour la
représentation j'ai utilisé une échelle
de couleur qui va du noir au jaune pour
représenter les valeurs entre 0 et 1 et
la valeur dans chaque case vous pouvez
l'avir comme un niveau de vie de la
cellule ou une concentration d'une
certaine substance vitale bon mais si
maintenant chaque cellule peut avoir une
valeur continue entre 0 et 1 comment on
peut adapter les règles d'évolution pour
le comptage des voisines bah on peut
garder la même idée mais faire cette
fois la somme des valeurs des h voisines
la seule différence c'est qu'au lieu de
récupérer un nombre entier bien on va
avoir un nombre réel compris entre 0 et
8 et qui va représenter le voisinage de
la cellule il va donc falloir adapter
les règles on peut plus se contenter de
dire que la cellule survit avec deux
voisins et apparaît avec TR il faut
imaginer un truc continu par exemple
avec une courbe de ce genre qui donne le
nouvel État en fonction de la somme des
voisines sur cette courbe ça veut dire
par exemple qu'une cellule qui a une
somme de voisines de 2,5 recevra la
nouvelle valeur 0,75 mais on peut
imaginer tout un tas de formes
différentes pour cette courbe donc avoir
un état continu pour les cellules c'est
jouable en revanche pour l'instant
l'écoulement du temps lui est toujours
discret on avance au tour par tour comme
dans le jeu de la vie mais on pourrait
chercher aussi à le rendre continu pour
pouvoir le faire avancer petit à petit
pour ça il faut modifier un peu le sens
de cette courbe qui indique quoi faire
en fonction de la somme des voisins on
va l'interpréter non pas comme le nouvel
état de la cellule au tour suivant mais
comme son taux de
croissance par exemple ici avec une
valeur de 2,5 en somme des voisins on a
la valeur de 0,5 ça veut dire que la
croissance sera de 0,5 par tour mais si
on veut faire avancer le temps de
seulement un demi-tour ou un quart de
tour ou même un milliè de tour on peut
on applique le taux de croissance
pendant la durée indiquée et on peut
traiter le temps comme s'il était
continu et bien sûr sur cette courbe
quand on a des valeurs négatives ça
indique une décroissance de la cellule
par exemple quand il y a trop ou trop
peu de
voisinage évidemment une petite
subtilité c'est qu'avec cette idée de
taux de croissance
on peut se retrouver avec des cellules
qui dépassent la valeur de 1 ou qui au
contraire vont finir en dessous de zé on
ajoute donc juste une règle
supplémentaire qui dit qu'on limite les
valeurs entre 0 et 1 à ce stade les
états des cellules sont continu et le
temps est continue et bien la dernière
étape c'est de rendre l'espace continu
comment éviter cette idée de division un
peu arbitraire en cellule et bien on va
remplacer la règle de compter les
voisines immédiates par une règle du
genre
compter toutes les cellules dans une
certaine zone par exemple pour chaque
point on pourrait calculer la moyenne
des valeurs des cellules situées dans un
certain rayon r tout autour la notion de
voisine immédiate disparaît et est
remplacée par une idée de proximité
encore mieux on pourrait faire la
moyenne dans une certaine zone en nano
comme ça ça se rapprocherait de ce que
fait le jeu de la vie ou en comptant les
voisines immédiates on regarde une sorte
d'anneau autour de la
cellule alors techniquement calculer la
moyenne des voisines en pondérant de
cette façon c'est ce qu'on appelle
appliquer un filtre et alors je vous
passe les détails mathématique mais
cette idée de compter avec un filtre ça
s'appelle une opération de convolution
et ça s'écrit très bien de façon
parfaitement Contin continu sans qu'il y
ait besoin de diviser explicitement le
monde en petites cellules alors
évidemment pour faire le calcul on va
quand même devoir découper le monde en
case mais on pourra choisir ces cases
aussi petites qu'on le souhaite et on
s'est donc affranchi de l'idée d'un
espace forcément fait de cellules
discrètes de taille fixe alors résumons
où nous en sommes je vous ai proposé
trois changements trois manières de
généraliser le jeu de la vie prendre des
valeurs continues entre 0 et 1 dans les
cellules sonder le voisinage en
utilisant un filtre par exemple un
filtre en ano et passer le résultat dans
une fonction de croissance qui va
déterminer un taux d'évolution de la
cellule et ces trois idées constituent
les principes de base de lenia et forme
ce qu'on appelle un automate cellulaire
continu alors si ça vous intéresse j'ai
écrit un code Python pour montrer
comment on fait toutes ces adaptations
je le partagerai en description et cette
formulation ouvre plein de nouvelles
possibilités pour essayer de trouver des
règles qui engendrent des comportements
émergents intéressants tout ce qu'il
faut faire c'est choisir un filtre
choisir une fonction de croissance et
simuler et ben c'est
parti
les principes de lenia ont été décrits
pour la première fois par le chercheur
Bert Chan en 2019 il a notamment montrer
qu'en choisissant bien les règles on
pouvait retrouver toute une zoologie de
motifs comme dans le jeu de la vie des
motifs qui ressemblent vraiment à des
créatures virtuelles par exemple prenons
un simple filtre en anneau et une
fonction de croissance qui est une forme
gasienne comme ça on retrouve bien
l'idée qu'il y a une sorte de zone de
croissance mais qu'avec trop ou trop peu
de voisin il y a une décroissance due à
l'isolation ou à la
surpopulation et avec ça regardons la
configuration initiale suivante une
simple tâche ici la valeur de chaque
cellule est donc représentée par une
couleur qui va du noir au jaune en
passant par le violet on a des cellules
qui ont des valeurs proches de 1 au
centre et ça décroit quand on s'éloigne
si on lance la simulation à partir de
cette situation initiale voici ce qu'on
obtient il se passe quelque chose
d'intéressant on voit que ça évolue que
que des motifs se forment et qu'ils
envahissent en quelque sorte l'espace
disponible jusqu'à se stabiliser alors
ça n'est pas tout à fait comme dans le
jeu de la vie mais c'est prometteur
maintenant considérez la configuration
initiale suivante le motif que vous
voyez ici a été découvert par berchan et
baptisé hor biome c'est toujours le même
code couleur he jaune pour les valeurs
élevées violet orange pour les
intermédiaires et noir quand c'est
faible ou nul si je lance la simulation
avec les mêmes paramètres de filtre et
de croissance qu'avant voici ce que
j'observe le motif se déplace et à
nouveau j'insiste pour ceux qui
trouveraient ça banal en fait à aucun
moment dans les règles on a codé une
notion de déplacement le déplacement
émerge des règles microscopiques comme
c'était le cas avec le planeur dans le
jeu de la vie ah oui et petit détail
noté au passage que depuis le début
j'utilise sans le dire ce qu'on appelle
des conditions périodique les cellules
d'un bord sont considérées comme en
contact avec cell du bord opposé donc
quand le biome sort d'un côté il r
rentre de l'autre l' biome est amusant
car on dirait vraiment une créature he
comme une sorte de mollusque avec une
structure interne et notamment ce qu'on
appelle en biologie une symétrie
bilatérale pour comparaison je vous
redessine à la même échelle le filtre en
anneau qu'on utilise pour compter les
voisines et c'est intéressant d'en faire
une interprétation comme une sorte de
faculté sensorielle d'une certaine façon
le filtre permet à chaque point de la
créature de sentir son voisinage à une
certaine distance et d'évoluer en
fonction alors malgré tout l'or biome
est un motif qui reste assez
exceptionnel et plutôt fragile si vous
partez d'une configuration initiale
aléatoire vous allez toujours retrouver
les mêmes motifs qu'on avait avec la
tachche même si la façon dont ces motifs
progress c'est quand même intéressant et
pour avoir des créatures encore plus
riches et impressionnantes il va falloir
un peu améliorer les règles de base une
première amélioration simple c'est
d'utiliser un filtre plus complexe
composé par exemple de plusieurs anneaux
d'intensité différentes cela revient
d'une certaine manière à pouvoir sentir
le voisinage à différentes distances
avec cette règle on peut voir émerger
cette créature baptisée
hydrogénium on retrouve une symétrie
bilatérale et cette fois le déplacement
n'est plus totalement linéaire comme
avec l'orbiome ou le planeur du jeu de
la
vie on voit la créature tourner
légèrement d'un côté puis de l'autre
dans cette exemple on a donc utilisé un
filtre plus complexe mais toujours la
même fonction de croissance mais on peut
également choisir d'utiliser plusieurs
filtres ayant chacun sa propre fonction
et de sommer les contributions cela
permet des comportements différenciés en
fonction de ce qui est senti en quelque
sorte par les filtres aux différentes
distances voici un exemple d'une
créature obtenue avec un système de ce
genre
elle ressemble à un orbium mais on
retrouve ce déplacement non linéaire
qu'on avait avec hydrogénium
mais l'amélioration la plus intéressante
ça consiste à utiliser plusieurs canaux
depuis le début je vous ai dit que les
valeurs qu'on représente qui sont
comprises entre 0 et 1 on peut les
interpréter soit comme des
intermédiaires de niveau de vie soit
comme par exemple la concentration d'une
certaine espèce chimique mais s'il
pouvait y avoir plusieurs espèces
chimiques présentes c'est-à-dire que
dans chaque case on ne stocke pas une
seule valeur entre 0 et 1 mais plusieurs
disons trois valeurs indépendantes ça
veut dire qu'on pourrait avoir des
endroits qui contiennent beaucoup d'une
substance mais peu des deux autres ou
l'inverse pour visualiser ce qu'on a
quand on a trois valeurs c'est plus
compliqué qu'avant mais on peut utiliser
une représentation en rouge vert et bleu
voici un exemple ce que vous voyez ici
c'est un motif de départ où dans chaque
pixel on a stocké trois valeurs une
qu'on représente en rouge l'autre en
vert et la dernière en bleu et la
couleur de chaque pixel résulte du
mélange des trois et donc par exemple
les zones magenta contiennent du rouge
et du bleu celles qui sont jaunes c'est
du vert et du rouge et puis en blanc ce
sont les pixels où on a les trois
substances présente en quantité proche
de 1 on dit donc qu'on a maintenant
trois canaux de simulation
ensuite il faut adapter les règles pour
tenir compte de ces multiples canaux en
pratique on va permettre à chaque canal
de sentir les autres avec un filtre
dédié et d'y réagir par une fonction de
croissance on imagine par exemple que le
canal bleu soit capable de sentir le
canal vert dans son voisinage et que le
vert sente à la fois disons le bleu et
le rouge en créant ainsi plusieurs
filtres qui connectent les différents
canaux on peut voir émerger des
comportements très intéressants par
exemple ici voici ce qu'il se passe avec
ma configuration initiale c'est vraiment
très chouette he on voit notre motif se
déplacer et se séparer en deux pour
former une structure mobile plus grande
et symétrique c'est assez dingue hein
c'est presque comme une sorte de
division
cellulaire il existe encore toute une
zoologie de motifs qui ont été mis en
évidence je vous renvoie aux vidéos de
bertchan sur sa chaîne Youtube mais vous
voyez déjà avec mes quelques simulations
que l'enia est un système extrêmement
riche et intéressant qui promet
d'étendre beaucoup ce qu'on arrivait à
faire avec le jeu de la vie de Conway la
principale difficulté c'est que l'enia
est tellement riche que l'espace des
possibilités est énorme entre les
filtres les fonctions de croissance le
nombre de canaux et les configurations
de départ la quantité de choix de
paramètres à effectuer est considérable
avant d'espérer peut-être trouver une
créature intéressante au départ la seule
solution disponible consistait à essayer
des trucs au hasard et à chercher à la
main si on trouvait des motifs
intéressants prometteurs ce qui est
évidemment très fastidieux à la longue
mais ces dernières années une équipe de
lineria à Bordeaux a eu l'idée d'adapter
des méthodes de machine learning pour
cette
tâche le machine learning c'est cette
discipline qui s'intéresse à la façon
dont des algorithmes peuvent apprendre
et c'est notamment ce qui est à la base
de la Révolution actuelle en
intelligence artificielle j'en ai parlé
de nombreuses fois sur la chaîne si vous
connaissez un peu le fonctionnement des
réseaux de neurones il y a peut-être des
choses dans l'enia qui vous ont
interpellé on parle de filtre d'une
fonction de croissance qui vient en
quelque sorte activer le signal après
filtration ça ressemble pas mal au
vocabulaire des réseaux de neurones et
notamment de ce qu'on appelle les
réseaux récurrents dans lesquels ce qui
sort du réseau lui est réinjecté en
entrée lenia dans sa forme originelle
n'a pas exactement la bonne structure
mais il a été possible d'adapter sa
paramétrisation pour la rendre plus
similaire à certaines architectures de
réseau de neurone et cela a ouvert la
porte à l'utilisation de tout un arsenal
de technique permettant d'explorer
efficacement l'espace des
possibilités ainsi l'équipe flowers de
linriia a utilisé des méthodes qu'ils
avaient initial ement mise au point pour
l'entraînement des réseaux de neurones
des méthodes s'inspirant de notions de
psychologie du développement et de
neuroscien comme la curiosité et la
motivation intrinsèque alors il faudrait
vraiment que je consacre une vidéo à ces
méthodes mais il faut savoir qu'elle se
prête très bien à la découverte de
nouvelles structures intéressantes dans
l'énorme espace des paramètres de lenia
et c'est ainsi qu'ont été découvert
d'autres motifs encore plus
intrigants par exemple celui-ci qui
arrive à à naviguer autour d'obstacle à
les
contourner et même à parcourir un
labyrintte
un point faible des premiers motifs
lenia c'était leur stabilité comme dans
le jeu de la vie la moindre modification
pouvait les détruire mais on connaît
maintenant des motifs qui résistent très
bien aux perturbations par exemple qui
sont capables de se reconstituer si on
les endommage si on injecte du bruit ou
bien s'ils sont attaqués par des balles
virtuelles certains de ces motifs sont
aussi capables de se déplacer en
fonction de la présence d'un un certain
signal sur un canal c'est un phénomène
qui se rapproche de ce qu'on appelle la
chimiotaxie chez les bactéries et qui
leur permet de diriger leur mouvement en
fonction de la concentration de
certaines espèces
chimiques et aussi bien sûr on a trouvé
plus de motifs capable de se reproduire
une des caractéristiques les plus
importantes de la vie avec même comme
ici un cas de reproduction de deux
individus qui en engendrent un
trè en ajustant encore les règles de
base de lenia les scientifiques ont pu
pu plus facilement découvrir des formes
stables et même les mettre en
compétition dans une sorte d'écosystème
virtuel et observer des premiers
éléments de sélection
naturelle ces dernières années l'enia
s'est imposé comme l'un des systèmes de
vie artificielle les plus prometteurs
permettant d'étudier avec un nombre
restreint de règles certains phénomènes
émergents qui caractérise la vie au sens
large on l'a vu ces découvertes ont été
grandement accélérées par l'adaptation
de ces méthodes de machine learning qui
facilitent l'exploration de l'espace des
paramètres et il est vraisemblable que
le panel de créatur virtuelle continue
de s'enrichir dans les années à venir
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo un merci
tout particulier aux chercheus et
chercheur de l'équipe flowers de
l'indria avec qui j'ai eu le plaisir
d'échanger je vous mets plein de
références en description abonnez-vous à
la chaîne je continue de le dire car
YouTube diffuse de moins en moins mes
vidéos hein c'est dommage et en
attendant je vous dis à très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo à
[Musique]
bientôt